of Law and crime daily we're updating
you on some of the bombshell
developments from the newly released
probable cause affidavit in the murder
of four college students plus this is
the state of Idaho versus Brian
culberger the suspect appears in front
of an Idaho judge to hear the heinous
charges against him as parents of the
victims look on it's obviously an
emotional time for the family seeing the
defendant for the first time
and experts help provide clarification
and insight on what's next for the
investigation and what we still have not
learned doing things fast is not as
important as getting things right long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Brian coburger the man
accused of slaughtering four University
of Idaho students inside of a home will
stay behind bars we are bringing you the
biggest takeaways from Thursday's
shocking probable cause affidavit
released just before coburger's first
Idaho court appearance so here's a look
at what we're going to be analyzing over
the next 30 minutes we now know that one
of the surviving roommates was actually
inside the home and awake when the
suspect walked right past her plus how
DNA evidence and a print found at the
crime scene helped police get closer to
the suspect and the Hyundai Elantra the
police have been looking on and being on
the lookout for that was spotted
multiple times near the victim's home
but what did the affidavit not tell us
what information is still missing and
where do we go from here well to help
answer that I'm joined by my co-host and
two legal professionals public defender
Brian buckmeyer and former trial
Attorney Terry Austin we're going to be
breaking this down for you piece by
piece but first we got a better look at
Brian coburger Thursday as he sat in an
Idaho Court for the very first time
during this initial appearance he
answered a few of the judge's questions
heard the charges against him and he was
denied bail long crime correspondent and
Jeanette Levy was inside that courtroom
and she joins us now from laeta County
Idaho and Jeanette walk us through the
hearing
well Jesse it was a very brief hearing
less than 15 minutes and this is really
a hearing where the judge reads the
charges against Brian coburger to him
and asks him if he understands and asks
him about whether he not wants appointed
counsel he has appointed counsel a
public defender here in Idaho is
representing him in this case he walked
in he sat down he didn't show any
emotion people have been asking about
that he answered yes when the judge
asked him if he understood the charges
very succinctly it was very sad though
to watch the victims families in the
courtroom Kaylee gonsalves's mother and
father were in there and before the
hearing started Steve gonsalves Kaylee's
father brushed some hair away from his
wife's face and then just gently kissed
her on the side of her head just in a
really loving comforting way when the
charges were read Christy Gonzalez
started crying as did another family
member sitting next to her so it was
just very sad sad thing to witness as
these families prepare for this long
legal Journey Ann Taylor is the public
defender representing Brian coburger she
said she wanted to note when asking for
bail whether that he has a family that
supports him she said that he should get
some type of bail the prosecutor here in
Layton County Bill Thompson said no he's
not eligible so he is being held without
bail and they are pursuing the death
penalty in this case that is a possible
punishment should Brian coburger be
convicted of these crimes following the
hearing the attorney for the gonsalves
family made a statement outside of the
courthouse
good morning everybody
um my name is Shannon gray I'm the
attorney for the Gonzalez family
we're not going to be taking any
questions at all
um it's obviously an emotional time for
the family seeing the defendant for the
first time
this is the beginning of the criminal
justice system and the family will be
here for the Long Haul and that's the
statement for the media today thank you
and they will be in for a long haul
since this is a death penalty case and
we know that this was a seven-week
investigation an investigation that is
certainly continuing there's still a lot
of evidence that the defense attorneys
will have to obtain through the
discovery process they'll have to Wade
through that and look through it and so
this will be a possibly a very long
process as we head toward that next
court date which is a status hearing on
January 12th Jesse and Jeanette great
reporting thank you a whimper and a loud
thud that is one of the lines from the
probable cause affidavit that really
stands out this audio was recorded by a
security camera near the home after 4 AM
The Night of the murders one of the
surviving roommates who was identifying
as DM said that she thought she heard
someone say there's someone here then
later she heard she thought that she
heard crying coming from zana's room she
opened her door and heard a male voice
say it's okay I'm going to help you when
she opened the door a third time she
says she saw a person black clothing and
a mask walking towards her she said that
she was five foot ten or taller not a
very muscular male bushy eyebrow she
said that she froze up and he walked
right past her after that DM told
investigators that she locked herself in
a room no one called 9-1-1 until the
afternoon Brian I got to get your
perspective on this I mean the
description that she made does that
co-burger I think so like I I know that
events is going to say it's late at
night or early in the morning depending
on how you look at it maybe she was
drinking the night before maybe she was
intoxicated maybe she was sleepy all of
those things are probably going to come
up in the defense is mine but I look at
those bushy eyebrows and co-burger I I
look at his frame I look at his size she
seems to have him down to a T and if
she's saying that he's walking right
past her she has every opportunity to
see every description that's going to be
a hard case Terry real quick 30 seconds
why did he not attack her you know I
think he was afraid of getting caught he
did the murders he was looking to get
out he didn't want to be identified if
he stopped and did another murder
cameras could have been in that hallway
and they could have identified him even
further so I think he just said let me
haul tail out of here and maybe I can
get away with this she's lucky to be
alive still ahead on Long crime daily
our coverage of the Idaho College
student murders continues as we break
down new information disclosed in a new
affidavit including what we now know
about the search for DNA match and how
police connected co-burger with the
Idaho crime scene
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we're
continuing to explore the newly released
affidavit in the Idaho College student
murders case and we can't leave without
the use of DNA and prints to identify
Brian coburger the affidavit states that
a latent shoe print was found inside
outside the door of DM one of the
surviving roommates from the attack the
shoe print had a diamond type pattern
time and type Soul pattern similar to a
Vans shoe now the print matches
coburger's point of travel that the
roommate described to law enforcement
during their alleged encounter in the
home when it comes to DNA the Idaho
State lab located a single source of
male DNA on a button strap or button
snap I should say attached to a tan
leather knife sheath that sheath was
found on Madison Logan's bed next to her
body Kaylee gonsalves was found dead
next to Mogan in the same bed the same
lab used trash recovered from the
co-burger family residence in
Pennsylvania to pin down the suspect you
see the trash was a probable match for
the biological father of the DNA found
on the sheath at the scene but is that
enough to get a conviction well forensic
death investigator Joseph Scott Morgan
came on the program Thursday to talk a
little more about it
this would have been an overwhelmingly
exerting
uh physical activity he would have been
engaged in just slaughtering these
people
adrenaline is up there's there would
have been muscle fatigue at this point
he would have been spent essentially by
this point in time so I think that
they're considering all of this a deep
dive into the the fiber and molecular
evidence contained in in that Moscow
residence is going to be required and
they're going to have to look through
every area of that house to see if maybe
he had been there before because they
can find in fact touch DNA in those
locations I'd be very curious to find
out if they're going to be searching
through closets all these places where
he could have hidden and all it takes is
to draw just a bit of DNA that's
connected back to these victims how's
the defense going to explain that away
how do you explain you know you might be
able to do it with one person but if you
get a collection of four individuals
that you've never met or they've never
crossed paths how do you explain that
away
Brian explain to us better what we're
talking about with the DNA that's used
to connect coburger to the murders and
do you think that is a strong connection
moving forward I mean JSM is doing my
job right there because I'll be honest
when I look at these cases I think all
right I'm a defense attorney how do I
break this case apart and prove that
this person is innocent I can't in this
case because what they're doing is
they're taking that sheath that's a part
of the murder weapon and left at the
scene next to one of the bodies of the
victims which is great evidence for the
prosecution and the police and they're
connecting to the trash in his house and
if they can find similar DNA of a victim
on him
I like JSM said I don't know a way to
break this apart because they're
connecting so many breadcrumbs that all
lead back
um to co-burger and that's just the DNA
we're not talking about the other pieces
so I think this makes it a dangerous
case for the defense but a great case
for the prosecution yeah I agree with
you let's talk about Terry about that
shoe print evidence right is that going
to be even admissible do you think it's
strong I do think it's strong it may not
be as strong as that DNA but they have a
unique shoe print they said it's diamond
shaped they said it's like a van shoe
you better believe they're going to be
looking for those shoes and even if Cole
Burger threw the shoes away he could
still have purchased those shoes if
there's a store that sells Vans they're
going to be going in and out of those
stores looking to see if they can find
receipts and so you know if they can tie
him to that shoe print and to that shoe
there is another piece of evidence right
there that that jury can connect to
co-burger and we've seen it done before
if you remember member in the Pike
County Massacre we saw George Wagner he
was convicted and part of the evidence
in that case was a shoe print so they
didn't find the shoe there they may not
find the shoe here but it could be one
of those connective dots to convict him
this might be the strongest but maybe
even having him on surveillance footage
of some kind wearing Vans shoes that
match that kind of description may be in
and of itself important but we'll see
well I'll tell you what you're going to
definitely want to stay with us as our
special coverage of the probable cause
affidavit in the Idaho College student
murders continues we're breaking down
how Moscow police connected Brian
coburger to that now Infamous white
Hyundai Elantra and why the car itself
could be so important
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody as we follow
brand new details on the Idaho College
student murders case we want to talk
about how police were able to track
Brian coburger and connect him to the
home on Kings Road which is not far from
the University of Idaho nearly two weeks
after the murder Moscow police put out
information about a white Hyundai
Elantra that they were looking for
something that we reported here on Long
crime daily on November 29th a
Washington State University officer
spotted a white Elantra in the parking
lot of an apartment complex coburger was
part of a doctoral program at wosc WSU
and the car came back registered to him
the car was spotted on several cameras
near the home including driving by the
house three times before the students
were killed 16 minutes later that same
car was seen speeding away from the
crime scene police also track coburger's
cell phone use the officer who wrote up
the affidan David says that coburger's
phone used the same cell phone tower
that provided coverage to the victim's
house at least 12 times prior to the
night of the murder between 2 47 a.m and
4 48 a.m on November 13th police allege
that coburger turned off his phone to
try to conceal his location when it
comes to proof that coburger was
connected investigator Joseph Scott
Morgan says that the car itself is a
critical piece of evidence
one of the things I'm very interested in
as a forensic science guy is that car
that car is a rolling crime scene in and
of itself and it has to be handled with
kit gloves at this point so they're
going to take this thing apart piece by
piece and they're going to use every
kind of technology that you can imagine
only seeing everything from alternative
lighting to luminol or blue star or
whatever they're using they're going to
take samples from all inside of the sink
because it doesn't matter how hard you
try to clean one of these things you are
not going to escape what we're capable
of doing in forensics and recovering
molecular molecular evidence
is Joseph the best I really I really
think he's the best he explains it so
well so Brian coburger's phone was
supposedly turned on and off during the
night of the murders explain to us how
the affidavit is showing that and why
it's so important in this case I mean
Jesse before the show you said it best
why didn't he just leave his phone at
home this is probably the biggest part
of consciousness of guilt that the
prosecution is going to wave as a
massive flag whether it be uh throughout
the case at trial and if we get there at
sentencing this shows Consciousness that
hey I've been here 12 times not only
does my cell phone but photos of my
vehicle that correspond to the time that
my cell phone is pinging off of these
towers show me going from point A to
point B don't forget his school at WSU
and that of Idaho University are only
about 10 miles apart and it's a small
town area they're college towns and so
getting from point A to point B you
usually take typically the same type of
roads and so the the ability to track
the vehicle and the phone is huge in law
school we learned that arguments are
like bundles of sticks each individual
argument may be able to be broken but if
you put them together they're almost
unbreakable this case is a bundle of
logs any one of these arguments could
take down
the suspect here a co-burger and when it
comes to Tracking not just cell phones
because usually we get one or the other
but tracking cell phones and phones a
cell phone and cars sorry and putting
them together and showing the path as he
turns off his cell phone going towards
the victim's home during the night of
the shooting and it turns it back on as
he's leaving at the exact time of The
Killing
I think I could bury him oh yeah I mean
oh your phone just happens to turn off
at the exact point but Terry I'll tell
you it's not clear whether the police
have the cell phones of other family
members do you think that that evidence
could provide some information well
let's hope they've got everybody's cell
phone the affidavit did mention
obviously they have co-berger's cell
phone but they had DM cell phone and
they have at least one of the victims I
think it's safe to assume that they have
the cell phones of all of the victims
but I think just as important would be
the cell phone of all of the people in
that Circle close to Coburg so for
instance the mother I mean was she
texting anyone we know that she was in
court at one point she was very upset
does she know something the father he
was in the car when they were driving
from one point back to Pennsylvania so
does he know something did coburger text
his parents you know that could show
consciousness of guilt and it would be
admissible in court particularly if it's
an exception to hearsay like maybe
there's an admission there so I
definitely think it's important to look
at all of those other cell phones and
someone could come forward and said hey
I had an odd conversation with Mr
coburger at a point in time remember
that can come in too and if he says
anything in jail that can come back to
hurt him as well when we come back a
look at the highest priority questions
that we still don't have answers to plus
why those who complained about a lack of
information from police may have a
little crow to eat right
now
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Long Prime daily and our
in-depth coverage of the unsealed
affidavit in the murder of the Idaho
four there is a lot of information that
we learned from that document that
really stopped everyone in their tracks
but there's also a lot of things that we
don't know law enforcement consider
Brian coburger as the sole perpetrator
in the murders but we still don't know
if the 28 year old Pennsylvania man has
anything to do with the college students
living in Idaho we do know that he was
studying at Washington State University
but exact connections haven't been made
earlier this week we learned that the
victim's parents are working with law
enforcement to try to connect those dots
the affidavit also mentions just one
piece of DNA at the crime scene
connecting back to coburger the knife
sheath found on Madison mogan's bed with
the victims found brutally stabbed in
two separate locations there are
potentially more clues in the home on
Thursday we heard from trial consultant
Sunny Slaughter who emphasis size the
importance of justice and also patience
in this type of case
important as
important not for the public as much as
it is for the family
of Kaylee and Madison and zaina and
Ethan to know that Justice is working
in a process that will hopefully secure
them
not Justice in the sense that they will
ever forget but ensuring that whoever is
guilty of this crime is no longer out
and about to commit it again
so Brian we learned where the victims
were found but what the affidavit cut
short of doing was describing the
murders itself so what is missing there
yeah it's the autopsy report it's the
medical examiner's report uh we of
course know there it's a homicide it's
not an accident or something or a
natural death uh but what I'm looking
for and especially when you read that
first page and it says redacted just
before it gets into the two victims who
are found in the bathroom what do these
injuries look like who got more injuries
than the others did some injuries look
more brutal uh to some victims than to
others we already heard some of that
from some of the parents describing the
difference of the injuries but I think
if we look into the medical examiner's
report we're going to get a lot more
from the picture so far the affidavit is
telling us who and why they believe it's
who but I want to know the how this all
happened of course that sheath gives us
more information and probably that's why
we were led to believe that this is that
unique marine or or military used weapon
but I want to know about the injuries
that's going to to give us a lot more
information and basically what you're
saying Brian is we don't have the why we
don't have a motive here and based on
the information Terry what is the motive
here why would he have done this do you
think the prosecution is going to
explain the motive that seems to me to
be the central question well you know I
think there might have been two separate
motives here or potential Motors here
and the prosecution as you know doesn't
have to prove a motive but it's always
nice to be able to explain the story I
think the first motive could have been
the fact that he is obsessed with
criminology he has a masters in
criminology he's working towards his PhD
he studied under an expert serial killer
who knows how to define and to locate
serial killers not the fact that the
professor was a serial killer but he
knows how to find these people and so I
think it's clear that kohlberg is
obsessed with this and you know if
that's not the motive and I think that's
part of it he thought he could get away
with it but clearly he didn't he left
Brian talked about some of the things
that he left behind in terms of his DNA
the shoe print the car all of these
things but if that's not the motive then
it could very well be the fact that one
of these women might have crossed his
path they probably didn't even know it
because we have seen that these other
people were talking about the fact that
coburger just was arrogant and that he
got upset all the time if you turned him
down so I definitely think that that
could be an alternate second motive
there but we'll see if the prosecution
talks about it and we know that based on
the evidence he was possibly tracking
them so planning this it gives it just
another indication and all this Brian
Terry great job going through this
everyone thanks for joining us we will
see you next time as we discuss Justice
in America
foreign